don't please you're going for a dramatic
entrance at the last possible frigging
second that would be a really great time
for a game with so many strong
personalities battle-worn somehow lacks
a cohesive identity every facet from the
character's to the progression to the
visual presentation feels overloaded
with ideas some good some bad some just
confusing because it throws so much
against the wall the end result is a
scattered grab bag of manic gameplay
complex leveling and cartoony humor in
short battleborn is fun but messy and
parsing the experience underneath can be
maddeningly tricky great I have to
prepare another underling for imminent
Mortal Kombat the best example of
battleborn steep seated identity crisis
is its massive 25 character roster
though technically a first-person
shooter the game's heroes utilize all
sorts of preset weapons abilities and
roles that pull from every influence
imaginable impressively even characters
that seems superficially similar
inevitably offers something unique that
makes their gameplay memorable and
enjoyable be it a particularly powerful
super or simply a higher-than-average
movement speed this mechanical variety
is not only remarkable it also drives
battle borns longevity you'll unlock new
hero steadily and without much conscious
effort so you'll generally have one or
two new options by the time you've
outgrown your current character
unfortunately you might outgrow them
more quickly than you'd expect testing
out a new hero for the first time can
feel the fit overwhelming but as soon as
you overcome this initial teething
period each hero's gameplay loop starts
to grow routine this is in part a
symptom of battle borns approach to
action its gameplay is fast and frantic
but also light and loose I found I
generally just had to spam the primary
attack button trigger my specials
whenever possible and occasionally
retreat to let my shields recharge
lighting this this is especially true
during the cooperative campaign which
consists of eight loosely connected
missions that feel more like destiny
strikes that a carefully crafted
narrative driven story mode enemies are
for the most part brainless and
predictable
cutting them down in droves can feel
empowering but it also underscores the
repetitive simplistic nature of the
baseline combat it's also somewhat
frustrating that all eight missions
repeatedly remix the same three
scenarios defend the asset escort the
robot and kill the boss thanks to the
variety of the characters and the
frenetic energy of the combat however
better work can still end up being a
blast
sure the moment-to-moment gameplay feels
superficial but when your five-man squad
is getting absolutely swarmed and you've
already sunk 45 minutes into a mission
and you run out of respawns the tension
and chaos combine to form a powerful
engine of fun
a word of warning though without other
players combat becomes the slog and
certain objectives become nearly
impossible but hey at least they're
split-screen co-op and streamlined
matchmaking outside of the 8 campaign
missions battleborn offers 3 competitive
multiplayer modes and here the gameplay
develops a slightly more strategic Sheen
unlike the mindless water you fight in
the campaign multiplayer pits heroes
against heroes which forces you to
approach combat more thoughtfully the
modes themselves at an extra layer of
strategy as well
borrowing MOBA elements to create setups
that emphasize objectives over kills in
practice this equates to action that
feels less chaotic but far more
involving in anything in the campaign
and the combination of distinct
characters and MOBA inspired objectives
makes battle borns multiplayer feel
genuinely fresh this component is by no
means flawless however the added
strategic depth helps but doesn't
eliminate the simplicity of the core
gameplay but more importantly there's
just not quite enough content to make
battle born feel totally substantial the
three modes offer just two maps apiece
and while that's not unusual for a MOBA
it's awfully light for a shooter
especially one with a relatively short
unadorned campaign there's also an issue
with battle burns in match leveling
system the game features several forms
of experience in progression including
individual character leveling unlockable
gear and an overall command rank but the
most impactful system is the on-the-fly
leveling that occurs within each mission
and match in the campaign this system
works remarkably well I never felt
hindered starting at 0 but I was always
glad to have my fully leveled abilities
back by the end in the competitive
multiplayer however this system rewards
players who are already doing well
meaning matches and sometimes snowball
into lopsided thrashings while it may
not be as important as the progression
system or multiplayer modes it's worth
noting the battle horns riding is by and
large goofy witty and endearing fun fact
this stuff used to be illegal but now
that we're all doomed nobody seems to
care holy crap legendary gear identified
holy
no you want to feel that everyone's
tastes but anyone can appreciate the
deep well of one-liners that flavor both
the campaign and surprisingly the
competitive multiplayer battleborn feels
like an elaborate patchwork of ideas
that compete for attention without
necessarily adding too much the
experience with so many moving parts
that never quite jell I found plenty of
things to love but just as much to feel
confused by and ambivalent about
you